ah ouais ah
ou l'égalité des chances pour tous le
projet ville-avenir était inauguré ce
jeudi 11 janvier à Versailles un lieu de
vie pensé comme un espace pour la
réussite de jeunes de 16 à 25 ans
accompagné par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance des parcours de vie souvent
difficiles que la structure accompagne
grâce à des solutions éducatives
innovantes nous avons une jeune fille
qui est actuellement en train de
préparer Science Po et qui bénéficiera
d'un mentorat de quelqu'un qui a le même
parcours qu'elle mais pas que ça en
fonction des compétences qu'elle a à
développer on lui proposera tout un un
certain nombre d'ateliers d'activités de
rencontres inspirantes bien sûr il faut
que ce soit des des jeunes qui a un
talent mais surtout qui fassent la
démonstration de leur capacité à
s'engager véritablement de manière
authentique et dans leur travail pour
que le leur projet soi rendu possible
dans cette village ch garde accollé au
domaine de Madame elliisabeth six jeunes
sont accompagnés en internat depuis
septembre 2023 un lieu permettant
l'accès à des études mais aussi le
développement de nouvelles compétences
gestion des émotions communication ou
méthodologie d'apprentissage des projets
individualisé et surmesure pour regagner
en confiance c'est vrai que c'est un
privilège parce que je suis une moi-même
une enfant de laad enfin j'étais une
enfant de laad laad c'est l'ancêtre de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance donc je me
reconnais dans ces parcours de vie de
ces jeunes dans tout ce qui a pu les
malmener finalement depuis leur plus
tendre enfance à un moment où ils
auraient dû être tout simplement
insouciant voilà et simplement des
enfants on est vraiment convaincu que la
qualité du cadre la qualité de
l'emplacement vont les aider à réussir
une vie qui faut bien le dire était pas
forcément bien partie pour eux 1 million
d'euros ont été investie par le
département pour réhabiliter cette
maison à la rentrée 2025 le site devrait
s'agrandir pour accueillir en interne
une douzaine de jeunes dans les ivines
près de 7000 enfants sont accompagnés
chaque année par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance